على الجانب الروسي افاد حاكم مقاطعه
كورسكا الروسيه بتواصل القصف الاوكراني
منذ صباح اليوم واشار الحاكم الى ان القصف
طال احياء عده والحق اضرارا ماديه باكثر
من عشره مباني سكنيه دون وقوع اي اصابات
في صفوف المدنيين
بثت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه صورا قالت انها
الاستيلاء قوات روسيه على دبابات المانيه
من طراز اليوبارد وعربات بوشات قتاليه
امريكيه من طراز البرادلي في محور
ما حدث ايضا في كورسكا اليوم والقصف
المستمر ما اخر تحديث بخصوصه
نعم مريم كورسك هي جزء من مشهد متكامل
هكذا ترى السلطات الروسيه وتتعامل مع كل
ما يجري اكان على ارضها وحتى في المقاطعات
التي ضمتها اليها في السابق في كورس وبيل
جرود ايضا تتعرض لقصف اوكراني مستمر
تتعامل معه السلطات ويؤدي بطبيعه الحال
الى ضحايا في كثير من الاحيان وخسائر
كبيره في هذا المشهد الميداني ايضا مدينه
دنيتك التي نتواجد فيها عدد من الجبهات
نحن في منطقه كييفسكي من الصعب عاده ان
نصل الى هذه المنطقه بفعل القصف المكثف
لانها تبعد نحو 6 كيلومترات فقط عن جبهه
افديفكا الشماليه هذه الجبهه التي تصف
فيها وزاره الدفاع القتال بالمستعر قبل
قليل كانت اصوات القصف المتبادل مرتفعه
بشكل كبير حيث نتواجد نحن في كييفسكي هذا
القصف ادى يوم امس
اقتل امراه واصابه عدد من الاشخاص ولكن
اذا ما نظرنا الى الجبهات الاخرى المفتوحه
في مدينه
بالتحديد عند جنوب هذه المدينه جبهه
اوغليدار وجبهه مارينكا قتال مستعر لم
يستطع اي من الطرفين لغايه الان زحزحه او
تحريق خطوط الدفاع والقتال بالنسبه
للطرفين يجري الحديث عن قيام القوات
الاوكرانيه باعاده تموضع وكر وفر في
المنطقه الرماديه التي لا يسيطر عليها اي
من الطرفين هذه الروايه تتحدث عنها
المواقع الروسيه والمواقع العسكريه
الروسيه التي تتابع اخبار الميدان هذا
التقاطع بين مقاطعه
بالتحديد عند هذه المنطقه اطلقت القوات
الروسيه هجوما باتجاه القوات الاوكرانيه
ويستعر القتال على ذلك المحور ويمتد
القتال عند مقاطعه روجيا بالتحديد وفق
السلطات المواليه لروسيا الى نحو 150
كيلومترا اذا هناك جبهات متعدده في
دانياسك داخل المدينه وايضا خارج هذه
المدينه في المقاطعه ككل احد هذه الجبهات
هي جبهات بخموت تقول وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
انها تصد كل الهجمات الاوكرانيه كانت التي
تشنها من شمال مدينه باكموت وبالتحديد في
منطقه بيرخوفكاو او حتى من جنوب هذه
المدينه
شكرا جزيلا لك كارمن جو خضر من داني